fois ce n'est pas la presse écrite qui
nous est gratuit mais le cinéma stephen
frears l'auteur des liaisons dangereuses
nous offre une fable satirique sur le
monde des médias avec un titre qui
ressemble furieusement au titre de
certaines émissions
héros malgré lui mais quand le héros
s'appelle dustin hoffman
on ne résiste pas au plaisir de vous en
parler une école cornu langlois et
bernard ap le rencontrer
et peut-être musiciens danseurs ou kung
il est toujours comédiens imprévisible
insaisissable drôle de farfadets et vous
surprendre vous ne l'attendait pas
pratiquer la séduction à outrance aussi
agité perfectionniste à la ville quel
écran la pièce et pour bernie le
caméraman dustin dédicaces les 4es de
tous ces films je faisais mes films
c'est vraiment trop épuisant il pense
d'abord qu'il faut donc il le prévient
votre geste en volant d'abord autrement
tu arrives à complète
il ya des tas de gens comme ça en
amérique
surtout à hollywood
le jeu s'appelle au mieux que de défense
avant k'tu m'enfonce arnaqueurs minable
bernie la plante assiste au crash d'un
avion à cause d'une chaussure embourbé
il sauf quelques victimes dont une star
télé et devient ainsi héros malgré eux
je vous posais une question personnelle
avez vous déjà rencontré un héros dans
votre vie
malchance la télévision se trompent
d'individus et c'est son copain qui
accèdent à la gloire après ce conte
social tonique et corrosive quel film
aimeriez vous écrire dirigé en ayant le
rôle principal bien sûr un film avec
vous et moi dans mon premier succès me
l'aurait un oui je vais réfléchir
rendez vous donc on ce film qui devrait
être fantastique au érotico comique